madeleine de la mort est sébastien bovet
bonsoir un mot sur le g7
peut-être que ce sera l'élément le plus
concret des trois jours c'est à dire ce
désir d'envoyer des doses partout sur la
planète madeleine et le canada on n'a
pas encore les détails mais je promets
de mettre dans le pont 100 millions de
doses oui on ne sait pas si ça sera 100
millions de doses en comptant en
équivalent comptant ou véritablement des
doses physique ça reste à déterminer
mais on attendait en l'engagement du
canada en fait à peu près tous les pays
s'étaient déjà engagés à distribuer une
partie des surplus de leur surplus aux
pays en voie de développement aux pays
plus pauvres mais au canada on avait
bien du mal à s'engager à le faire parce
qu'on voulait pas promettre quelque
chose qu'on n'avait pas encore le canada
est pas encore en situation de surplus
oui on a commandé des millions de doses
oui on aura des surplus mais tant et
aussi longtemps que le canada ne les
avais peuvent physiquement je pense que
le gouvernement canadien était
extrêmement prudent mais tout à l'heure
dans le reportage de louis on voyait
goudils l'acquis le haut commissaire du
canada maintenant en grande bretagne
dire à savoir rien changé pour les
canadiens je pense que c'était ça la
préoccupation du gouvernement de dire
bon ce sera les canadiens d'abord qui
seront vaccinés puis ensuite on
s'occupera des autres pays parce que le
canada sauf erreur est un des pays où
père capitanat commandé le plus de
vaccins
je me suis alors vu un tableau dans new
york table puis canada arrivé 2e ou 3e
sur le nombre de vaccins commandés par
reçu mais commandé par rapport à la
population
oui et on dit que le canada a été
extrêmement agressif dans sa stratégie
de commandes de vaccins pour essayer de
les avoir le plus rapidement possible et
ça a été remarquée sur la scène
internationale mais le canada a assumé
ce choix là mais maintenant la pression
était vraiment trop forte
il n'aurait pas pu se permettre à
l'issue du g7 de ne rien promettre alors
que ses autres alliés le faisait
contribuer à cet objectif d'un milliard
de doses fournies pour l'épée
les plus beaux sites toutes les doses
comme en hiver le canada rencontrent ces
dix doses de vaccins que chaque canadien
pourrait recevoir donc il en a commandé
pour tout le monde et plus donc il va en
avoir sur plus certainement si les
autres si si d'autres vaccins sont
approuvés évidemment très bien fin de
session de votre côté sébastien on va
écouter monsieur legault premier extrait
peut on revient à parler ce que le plus
marqué les québécois c'est le succès
pense ne pas avoir peur de le dire le
succès de la campagne de vaccination ça
fait plusieurs plusieurs années qu'on
n'avait pas eu du succès dans notre
réseau de la santé je pense qu'on a avec
christian dubé fait la preuve que c'est
possible de changer les choses en santé
donc préparez vous entre autres je le
dis aux médecins de famille à l'automne
on va travailler très fort un changer
les choses alors un avertissement aux
médecins de famille qui est pas passée
inaperçue c'est ma fille en même temps
il dit la vaccination
on va se péter les bretelles quelques
secondes là dessus quand même et il sort
d'une session parlementaire qui
correspond à la le moment où on prend le
dessus sur la copie du livre vaccin
gagnent sont en train de gagner la
bataille contre les variants et où donc
il a légitimement le droit de se péter
péter les bretelles en même temps il est
tout à fait conscient pis c'est drôle
parce que ça occupé une bonne partie du
point-presse d'une faiblesse qu'il a il
pas pas d'arrogance mais il dit qu'il
faut qu'il se contiennent un peu plus
qu'il faut pas qu'il devienne trop
agressif ouais ou un patient en effet
paso aux attaques de ses adversaires
mais ça peut devenir de l'arrogance puis
on a l'impression que son pire ennemi
dans le fond c'est pas les partis
d'opposition s'est lui même et cette
arrogance que lui et son gouvernement
pourrait afficher rendons à césar ce qui
revient à césar la campagne de
vaccination c'est un succès la
nomination de christian dubé comme
ministre de la santé
ça passe comme un coup de génie
parce que monsieur dubé à régler bien
des choses en santé et livré la
marchandise pour utiliser une mauvaise
expression forte il a des succès
monsieur legault mais il faut aussi
faire attention de ne pas devenir trop
bas on va l'écouter là dessus il dit je
vous promets pas ce qu'on fait référence
notamment au fait quand il a engueulé
l'opposition doit vous aurez jamais de
comptes et vous dans ce coin là en
parlant du troisième lien le débat y
avait été là on pouvait qualifier ça
d'arrogant des attaques et la voici ce
qu'il dit de lui même
mon défi principal c'est continuer à
écouter les québécois peut-être moins
moche et comme je les ai faites la
semaine passée donc je veux rester zen
doit être beaucoup plus combatifs
politique moi mais c'est des deux côtés
il faut écouter n'est les questions de
l'opposition que les prétentions de
l'opposition jetons un être humain
ça me choque des fois d'entendre des
choses qui sont pas exactes et puis bon
mais il faut que je sois plus un soin
plus zen
oui bah il veut et il peut être combatif
parce qu'on l'a on va tomber dans une
année électorale où les les la politique
va reprendre ses droits c'est-à-dire
condé confine aussi la politique ont des
conflits de québec ont des consignes
aussi la politique les dernières
semaines à l'assemblée nationale nous
ont donné un avant goût de ce que
l'automne pourrait être avec le
troisième bien les les
les erreurs ou la situation dans
laquelle pierre peys cubaine s'est
retrouvé donc le gouvernement comme été
un peu exposés à des questionnements
plus pointues des partis d'opposition en
dehors de la kfw que c'était la coved y
avait rien à faire cet espace de dire
que tout glisser sur françois legault
est injuste dans cette position-là la
politique reprend un peu ses droits
et ça va faire en sorte qu'ils se doit
être peut-être un peu plus pic haussier
monsieur legault et il sait que ce qui
le guette où le danger qui le guette
c'est justement d'être peut-être un peu
trop agressif un peu trop combatif
parce que contrairement à monsieur
trudeau où on voit madeleine encore
aujourd'hui léger tva 20 sondages qui
montraient que les cas vraiment un pas
très important en faveur des libéraux au
fédéral c'est un autre monde au québec
monsieur legault il ya peut-être le
premier vise la combine est un éclat qui
remonté comme ça mais pas autant
monsieur legault et dans un an dans un
endroit unique en termes de popularité
en ce moment oui effectivement mais
justin trudeau et jean marc léger de la
firme de sondage léger le monde le
disait à son la scène fédérale
les prochaines élections le 6 y en a
pour être serré donc ça va faire partie
évidemment des calculs de justin trudeau
à savoir est ce que cette marge là est
assez grande pour à obtenir une majorité
parce que le but d'une élection si
justin trudeau décide d'en déclencher
c'est pas pour gagner une autre minorité
il va vouloir obtenir un mandat
majoritaire donc ça ça va rentrer
évidemment dans les calculs justin
trudeau a pas eu droit aux mêmes écarts
qu'à québec
et pourtant justin trudeau ont eu droit
lui aussi à toute l'attention médiatique
alors j'ai déjà entendu mois des
oppositions me dire franchement on n'est
pas si mal que ça sachant que je rentre
de toute l'attention en campagne
électorale dont on arrive à une carte à
peu près tout le monde est égal ou le
temps d'antenne est beaucoup plus
calculer donc l'opposition croit qu'elle
pourrait faire des gains face à justin
trudeau qui va se retrouver dans un
univers médiatique vous plus que
beaucoup plus équitable
il avait eu un temps d'antenne pour
reprendre au bon ce que vous dites
équitable lors du dernier
débat fédéral il était chef d'un nouveau
parti maxime bernier
qu'est ce qui se passe avec maxime
bernier on a l'impression que là il sait
plus quoi faire pour attirer l'attention
va voir des images
il a été arrêté au manitoba
parce que ce qu'on peut parce que il a
participé à la manif a fait un rallye
dont lui avait dit tu n'as pas le droit
parce que tu viens d'arriver tu dois
aller en quarantaine il a dit je m'en
fous je vous écoute pas voici le
résultat il a été arrêté par des agents
de la grc
il a tweeté et son parti de se poser en
victime en disant bon voyez-vous ce
qu'on fait à ce notre chef maxime
bernier a été injustement arrêtés cet
après midi par la grc au manitoba ses
torts et c'est donc là que j'ai eu ma
question que ceux qui se posent maxime
bernier vite vite il ne sait plus quoi
faire pour attirer l'attention
moi je pense qu'il le trouvait sa
réponse aujourd'hui et il s'est fait
arrêter par la police pour attirer
l'attention
tous on avait l'air pratiquement
orchestrée par tri j'avais l'impression
que le téléphone dans le véhicule où il
était était tout près a enregistré la
scène lorsqu'on lui a passé les menottes
il a dit on lui a demandé par la police
est-ce que vous avez une arme il dit non
je n'ai connu que mes mots que mes idées
pour me battre ça avait l'air tout à
fait calculés pour essayer de de se
donner le beau rôle là dedans et hier il
a envoyé une lettre à ses partisans pour
dire bon j'ai besoin d'argent demain je
me rends au manitoba
il est possible que je me fasse arrêter
par le despote le premier ministre de du
manitoba envoyez-vous tout ça c'était
c'est un peut calculer c'est sa façon
d'attirer l'attention c'est sa façon
d'amasser de l'argent aussi
oui mais est-ce que ça pour aller où
parce que il vaudrait il va rester dans
la marginalité va rester dans pour aller
où
sébastien soi même mais mobilisé
peut-être une base qui est
anti mesure sanitaire qui conteste les
meules et le port du masque et
l'interdiction de faire des
rassemblements
ils jouent aux martyrs donc moi je pense
que c'est un geste politique où il veut
comme madeleine ou d'y attirer
l'attention et réunir sur j'écoute pas
si c'est quoi la possibilité de prendre
de l'expansion avec 2 3% de la
population qui respectent pas les règles
sanitaires
mais c'est le il veut se présenter comme
le défenseur des libertés individuelles
au pays ils pensent pouvoir rassembler
du monde autour de cette idée là en
étant le martyre de cette cause là au
pays le champion libertariens donc ok
très bien
la semaine prochaine il ya eu un débat
est un débat sans fin
sébastien jusqu'où on doit utiliser un
passeport ou une preuve vaccinale à
québec l'on promet parce que la santé
publique avait dit un rapport qui s'en
vient donc on voit peut-être la fumée
qui ça il sera déposé la semaine
prochaine on aura des détails on
l'espère qui sera déposée la semaine
prochaine on nous avait dit que ce
serait cette semaine guillaume dit que
la santé publique est lente dans cette
façon de faire les choses donc on espère
que la semaine prochaine on va savoir si
la question c'est à quoi ça va servir se
passe pas vaccinale au delà de voyager
ce qu'on va l'exigé pour aller dans les
lieux publics par contre par exemple
c'est la question qu'on se pose on
espère avoir la réponse la semaine
prochaine dont madeleine de votre côté
qu'est-ce qu'on surveille
moi je surveille une journée
d'opposition du bloc québécois qui va
redéposer sa motion sur la loi ou le
projet de loi plutôt 96 à québec
souvenez vous il avait tenté d'obtenir
un accord unanime à la chambre des
communes et jody usain bolt y étaient
opposés mais l'oeil une autre façon de
faire pour essayer de faire adopter
cette motion là c'est par le biais d'une
journée d'opposition où chaque députés
de tous les partis vont devoir se
prononcer et ça ce sera intéressant
surveillée qui va voter pour qui va
voter contre et je sais notamment qu'au
parti libéral on essaie de on essaie de
serrer les rangs
est ce que tout le monde va voter en
faveur de cette motion là c'est plus
difficile en de faire adopter cette
notion là à lui
unanimité au parti libéral qu'en
demandant tout simplement à tout le
monde on ne dit rien lorsqu'on vous voit
vous demander et si vous êtes pour ou
vous êtes contre il ça se termine qu'un
bon mais je trouve à revenir du yap a
fini sa tournée il va à l'europe et
ensuite à l'otan il va revenir un jour
et ça se termine quand votre session le
23 juin
alors c'est beaucoup plus long qu'à
québec et il ya des projets de loi qui
sont pas encore passés il ya ces dix
entre autres sur la loi sur la
radiodiffusion là pour encadrer géant du
web
alors ça on vous surveille si ça va
passer ou non il y aussi 12 aussi un
projet de loi sur la croupe
carboneutralité pour avoir des comptes
rendus des plans pour atteindre zéro
émission d'ici 2050 donc il ya des
tractations qui se font toujours en fin
de session
mais là c'est d'autant plus important
pour un gouvernement qui veut ou non
faire passer des projets de loi sachant
patrice et je vous en parle chaque
semaine qu'on va peut-être avoir des
élections avait remarqué je vais
m'allonger que josé épargné je n'ai pas
posé la question aujourd'hui
moi je me dis que quand on le sera
assurément on va le dire d'une part
d'autre part
tout indique qu'il y en aura mais oui
ils peuvent reculer encore mais tout un
exil en europe mais s'est on avait
l'impression que cette semaine il
mettait la table pour déclencher des
élections à se trouver des prétextes de
dire que le parlement fonctionnaient pas
et le va et vient entre les
conservateurs et les libéraux ouais est
ce que ça sera vote en septembre vote
début octobre le toutes les combinaisons
ce qu'on appelle là le ton la sont
bonnes mais il serait étonnant c'est
comme ça madeleine à moins que vous il
serait étonnant qu'on se retrouve quoi
la mi octobre puis qu'on n'est pas une
campagne électorale au canada j'ai
entendu cette semaine les rumeurs
électorales ne sont pas uniquement
persistante
elles sont insistants donc à mon avis on
aura des élections
c'est très bien merci beaucoup à vous
deux bonne fin de semaine pour voir nos
émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne i cirdi